this is Dominic Dominic works at a
5-star restaurant called the pixel
palace they're some of videogames most
popular celebrities pop in to have a
drink
sometimes they share stories and even
secrets because as we all know what the
bartender ears is confidential isn't it
zom sitting there tending ball when in
watts on an arm and seen in a while
shake now shakes up where they nice
bloke are keeps to himself doesn't talk
much and one day he sits down and he
almost vodka on the rocks and he looks
at me he says you know what I love about
vodka lastly to town he says you can see
right through him
I'll said well the exactly Dini mother
sir
and he says well fences can be very
deceiving company and then she proceeds
to take off his mask ensure that she
compact wasn't her he at all he was a
she
not just a she a royal shields Princess
Zelda that took me totally by surprise I
said your highness what do you do why
you dressing up like this she said well
at first it started off karma means of
survival there's this really long story
about this guy who looked like a pig I
couldn't quite follow it but did
somebody Beck anyway and she said well
people when they think you're a guy they
they treat you different you know they
don't act like you're royalty or I think
I said your royal thing she says I know
that's part of late it's that everyone
treats you like you're an individual I
mean it's one thing to be female or to
be royalty but when you're both people
look you look differently so she said
she really got used to wearing the men's
clothing and talking the deep voice of
course I asked I said well what about
Lincoln doesn't does he know about this
she says no no he kill me we found out
about this and also what well don't you
think you should tell him that I miss
his kind of a big ordeal and she says no
he um he's kind of his own issues to
work out also what they make she says
well not everybody in my kingdom wears a
skirt of you know what I mean and I'll
said hello
he doesn't really wear the pants in the
relationship she says he is never long
pants I've worn pants more than he has
she said she finally want a defender
serve because you know being kidnapped
so many times can really go to your head
have you heard about Pete she asked us
at aii
another major so we chat a little longer
you know just was like to be a woman to
be a man I guess and all the sudden out
of nowhere link enters the room so we
both phrase I don't know we don't know
the muscle he sits down Rob next to a
boy next to him and what's ugly he says
give me a grasshopper he has a thing
look green on our don't know what it is
better to maybe I don't know so I go and
I make him his drink and he starts up
getting pretty close to shake like
uncomfortably close he puts his hand on
shoots back' says hey here buddy you
come here often and she can darling her
lower voices no he says well i think a
tall handsome drink of water like you
should combine in the wanton so I decide
to bodied a little bit I'll say even
mister L then that that might not be
Liam but the best idea
he's his cooler fault and I got this so
he starts rubbing his hat he says so
he'll around here of course I can't
imagine what's going on Selden said
right now but now she stays and
characters chic it says don't you have a
girlfriend a certain royal girlfriend
and like says Oh Zelda yeah yeah but uh
below
we got an understanding and chic in a
very angry tone says what kind of
understanding and he says well you know
she can't let's my sword swing both ways
you know don't wait a sheik of courses
really well does this happen often and
they says all that time chase she's
totally cool about a terror illegal but
this is about as uncomfortable as you
can possibly get I mean the tension you
could cut it with a Master Sword I mean
it was totally insane and Sheik against
a encanta says so Ben with all the men
he says earlier yeah 30mm and she casts
well who exactly and he says oh all the
great kid icarus Luigi be tire cast and
file implement there's also a brief
thing with Cuban at one point but they
didn't seal or go into that much so she
look at like she's ready to rip its head
off says so you've been with all these
men he says yeah sometimes we do it
three two time the Triforce of love we
called it well you couldn't get a bad 3
way in San Francisco and I say all
fairies have wings he said so he grabs
cheeks and they says so what do you
think I wanna
get in play my logic flip
it's just then that uh she took off and
disguised and sure she really was I
think link went itself it was pretty
embarrassing you could see it going down
his tights and they just stood there
looking at each other three minutes on
time three minutes not a word
I - I look at each other and so they
finally broke the silence and said you
must think I think no I'm the evil link
from the dark world yes yes and since
everything is office in the dark world
she need the crotch after that she had
enough still didn't put a costume back
on and stormed out of the bar I said
mrs. Z what about your drink and she
said he'll pay for it stormed out the
door well think slowly climbed up back
to the bar but the lame
gave a little shrug and said women can't
live with him cat sleep with a man not
in laugh of that so he said they're
crossing his legs but all of a sudden
walk next to him Sam has sat down in a
battle gear link starts to move in
really close he says well hey you had
some tall drink of water you come here
often now Sammis then took off her
helmet we turn the other way and said
never mind some people never learn maybe
some people don't want to learn I don't
know
you see a lot of strange things as a
bartender see a lot strange things at
the pixel palace so I'll see a lot of
strange things as a bartender at the
pizza palace now that ain't no lot sweat
you